I am Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Lewis Lapham he's the
editor and founder of Lapham quarterly a
quarterly magazine that curates the past
into the present your latest issue
intoxication is the theme what brought
you to say this issue has to be about
intoxication the Christmas season joy to
the world a cup of good cheer and so
forth I mean it was it's a holiday mood
you you mentioned in your opening essay
that man's thirst is unquenchable for
intoxication and then you you basically
cite Abraham Lincoln saying to
criminalize this is wrongheaded and
stupid and leads to a bad end I I
believe that I mean I as you know was
before I started this magazine six years
ago I was the editor of Harper's
Magazine for 30 years and wrote a number
of pieces against the drug laws yeah I
think the criminalization of marijuana
is wrong I even think the
criminalization of cocaine is probably
wrong I mean if you take it up into I'm
sure the at the level of the meth
amphetamine that strikes the kids in
places like Montana and heroin I try to
keep that out of people's hands but I
still don't think it's it's a it's it's
criminal
is there a particularly American issue
with intoxication yes I think I think
the Americans have had a complicated
relation with intoxication I mean the
Russians of course have always had a
problem without was their problem is
simply that they didn't have enough fun
they would always run out of vodka and
it was and winters were very cold I in
in the essay I connected to the American
sense of discovery
I mean intoxication is their becoming of
someone else or they're going to
somewhere else and
the sense of we are all making ourselves
up as we whatever take the raft down the
river of the Mississippi so that in an
American context because we are we're
constantly looking for that frontier or
that new new sense of self the self I
mentioned the the drinking the the word
symposium the Greek word for
philosophical discussion that the
literal meaning of the word is it
drinking together
do you think there that if there is a
particular problem in America with kind
of overindulgence or overdoing it is it
because in more rooted societies you
know that are rooted by history or
something else that you can free
yourself up every once in a while and
take a trip and come back but in the
u.s. perhaps then you get to the
frontier and then you you don't know how
to come back to who you were well I
don't know I mean I missed Oracle II a
lot of people came back from the
frontier I mean frontier was not an easy
place to be right and I think something
like nine out of ten who started out
returned I think it's the American
willingness to experiment I the former
librarian of Congress Daniel Boorstin
great historian who defines the colonial
experience in the of the Americans as
that of constant improvisation a man
always had to be prepared to become
somewhere somewhere or someone else and
he talks about the American experiences
of perilous transmigration and and the
the whole basis of our idea of liberty
is to I look out for your liberty to
protect my own in other words and the
idea is to give your fellow travelers
the widest range of expression and the
broadest horizon of sight talk in you
know about Lapham more generally I the
you started it in 2006 what what's your
aim with curating things from the past
to know our past is is to discover our
ourselves I mean it
do you feel that that's more urgent now
or is this always a consonant because
you you are quite curmudgeonly I'm
looking at a essay by Ron Rosenbaum from
the Smithsonian where you kind of wave
away the internet or you say Google you
lament Google for inadvertent censorship
in the way search engine optimization
Barry's good stuff with with dross you
like in Facebook too or you say Facebook
has many of the properties of the Holy
Inquisition I mean the NKVD and the
Gestapo were content aggregators so yeah
but you two are a Content aggregator so
how are you performing a different
function than Facebook well I'm trying
to open doors to readers of all kinds
and I'm trying to make available a
resource I'm not trying to date a mine
at to sell something
I mean television is is advertising and
increasingly advertising gets on to the
out of the Internet you know they're
trying to it's a pitch I'm not making a
pitch I'm saying here's something you
can learn from see how beautiful this is
although you know what's interesting I
don't disagree with what you're saying
and in many ways but television or kind
of video entertainment has changed where
now people strip out the ads I mean one
of the things that's interesting video
with HBO and things like I mean it's
always a commodity but you know
commodities including life booms
quarterly not a bad thing right no you
know one of the things that's
interesting is I mean you you bring a
huge historical perspective to you know
both to Harper's as well as obviously
Lapham's is this just the latest turn of
being a Cassandra that uh you know
things are just getting worse and worse
in America or have we actually reached a
point where we are no longer capable of
kind of historical self-examination when
you look forward are you worried that
we're you're you know we're going
downhill no I
well downhill I don't know about
well I mean I mean intellectually you
know economically socially whatever I
don't think so I mean I think you know
you have Henry Ford saying that history
is for the most part bunk I mean you
have Richard Hofstadter writing in the
in the 50s the anti intellectual
tradition and American society
experience you have the know-nothing
party of in the 1850s oh so that and and
it shows up in Tocqueville too I mean
the antagonism toward Nancy learning
long words I mean that is that's a
strain on the other hand the people who
founded the country and at the late 18th
century considered themselves what
natural philosophers I mean these were
people who studied beetles who collected
birds who wanted to know about
agricultural methods so we have you know
we have a very strong educational
self-improving strain in in the in the
American society I mean the two things
exist you know together you know put
against a broad array of say the
Internet in this explosion and access to
text do more people have more access to
more pass or do they just get lost in
the in the clutter they kind of get lost
in the stacks well that's the reason for
for curators I mean yes I'm a curator
here I'm you know I'm a like a museum
director and a lot of people who run
blogs are the same I mean when you you
know if you go to truth out or TruthDig
or Tom dispatch essentially these are
curated compilations anthologies and
there's going to be more and more and
more of that because as the Internet
becomes so crowded it is
incomprehensible so you're going to have
to find some source that you can trust
and in this it this of course is the
secret of all successful American
journalism that's the Reader's Digest
that's Time magazine poor richard's
almanack or Richard's Almanack I mean
this is the I can do with this what I
couldn't do with Harper's Magazine which
is to get different points of view on
the same theme alright well we'll leave
it there we've been talking to Lewis
Lapham the founder and editor of Lapham
quarterly the latest edition out now is
intoxication Lewis thank you for talking
very much for raisin TV I'm Nicola